morning from beautiful California I am
on my way to quest Diagnostics to get my
blood drawn that all then gets sent off
to inside tracker and I'll give me my
results when I get out there not
fantastic with needles well I get
through it today
that's my appointment just finished
there they don't allow you to actually
take any footage while you're inside for
the safety and security added up
something American the nurse said they
wasn't a lot of blood but it felt like a
lot of blood to me
like ten miles ended those vials so tan
wait see on what the results say find
out in the next week there's a life hack
for you if you want to make your journey
through the metal detectors an apple an
awful lot longer pack a USB condenser
mic which is essentially a huge dildo
sized dildo shaped magnet that comes up
all colors of the rainbow when you put
it through a scanner every single time
hello sir what is this it's a microphone
I do podcasts and things okay we're
gonna have to check it for schedule one
drugs and detonated all substances and
whatever else there is but I'm through
[Music]
Jonathan and curry from insight tracker
how are you today good thanks for having
us thanks for having us thanks for being
here thank you for having night yeah I
mean thank you for having me
thanks for coming it's awesome so can
you explain to the listeners at home who
you guys are and what inside tracker is
and what it does sure um so we work for
our inside tracker I handle mostly the
CrossFit division and Jonathan handles
endurance but we also are helping people
out with their overall health or healthy
aging and what insight Recker really
does is we look at biomarkers in your
blood that are scientifically tied to
performance overall health and longevity
and we create personalized
recommendations for foods supplements
and lifestyle changes to help you get
those biomarkers and optimize zones if
they're not already in there yeah it's a
serious serious subject isn't it I've
just come straight from mr. David
Sinclair's office at the Harvard Medical
School and it seems like longevity and
this more analytical assessment I mean
I'm wearing a whoop bunt right like I've
got always on heart rate tracking of is
it a trend that you can see at the
moment with Fitness that people are
starting to take this sort of stuff more
seriously definitely they're starting to
care so I've been at the company for
four and a half years now and when I
started it was all about you know we
needed to help explain why this is
something you should care about and now
it's at a point where everybody knows
what it is we have to show that we're
better and that our platform is more
advanced more analytical and more
personalized than anything else out
there so the dreams already been sold
yes why do you think that's the case why
people know about it now were they just
looking for marginal gains or is it the
just natural movement along with is the
technology so it continues what do you
think yeah I think it's a little bit of
both I think there's more coming out
about how you can improve longevity what
you can do to be better about yourself
there's a large group of people that are
either getting older they're seeing
their parents get older probably more
likely at least here in the state
with with baby boomers and so and so
people are are questioning their own
longevity and and looking at like what
can I do so that I don't get like that
or what can I do so that I can be with
my kids or you know something like that
as as they get older and and so people
are looking for a way to make that
actionable so I went through the process
as the viewers will be seeing throughout
this episode I went to quest Diagnostics
in Redlands in California and out the
other side of that I got my blood drawn
they got sent off to your lab and then
within a few days I had a bunch of data
that I waited for you to interpret on my
behalf because I didn't I didn't quite
understand what everything was but it
does seem mad to me that out of a is
quite a lot of blood it's like ten vials
yeah felt like that felt like it felt
like Heights but it wasn't um is it
seems so mad that you guys are able to
decipher so much about my diet my
training my lifestyle my cortisol levels
my free testosterone just from a couple
of hours of blood that I had drawn on
the opposite side of the country like a
week ago it's a mad mad concept it's mad
but if you think about it people are
looking for guidance and what's the most
reliable source of data it's not how are
you feeling today it's not you know it's
it's not these these I have a garment
and it tracks my sleep quality and it's
some nights it says I sleep for three
hours and some nights it says I'm I'm in
bed at seven o'clock but I'm not and and
people are looking for analytics and
people are familiar with you know going
to your doctor to get glucose and
cholesterol but it stops there and
there's so much more beyond just are you
sick today or are you you know it's
coming from the performance side of
things
who cares who how you compared to 300
million Americans or a human in general
it's it's all about how do you compare
to yours
for some of its training like your
training for someone that's eating like
you're eating and then you know you
might be you might need to be here you
might need to be here and you're
currently here and so it's that you know
1% 5% 10% whatever it is that there's
there's benefit to to getting there you
also the right that it seems so
primitive now when I think about the
fact that all of us are training in some
form especially if it's for performance
right you are looking to dial in
marginal gains if you read Ben
Bergeron's book chasing excellence at
the bottom he's got character and then
above that he's got process which is
making the most of minutes right that is
in its very essence the highest
resolution highest fidelity look at
marginal gains rate on and it does seem
super like prehistoric to not be
tracking sleep quality with something
better than I think I went to bed at 10
o'clock last read and the same thing it
would appear now with guys like yourself
is being rolled forward for blood work I
was talking to David and he said he's
got all of his data with you guys since
like 2011 yep yeah that's intense
yeah that's a cool part of our platform
is that you can no matter when you do
inside tracker you can upload past blood
test results and kind of putting in a
little ping of what you were doing at
that time in your life um so you can
notice trends and oh my you know glucose
was here at this time of my life this is
what I was doing
fast-forward six months this is the next
time I tested here's where it was and
all I was doing that so you can find
trends you know in the changes that
you've made to find out you know what
can really affect your glucose and and
how to get that marker to move so can
you talk to the listeners about some of
the athletes that you guys have worked
with yeah I mean we work with I mean all
types of athletes from CrossFitters like
myself who are just you know going to
stay healthy to the top-tier CrossFit
athletes that are going to the games
are there any household names that
people might know yeah we've tested
Katrin is a big supporter of ours
Katherine David Sutter she works with
Ben Bergeron who's talked about inside
tracker before Cole Sager Scott panchik
who's going to the games for the ninth
time now we've worked with TIA we've
worked with all of the Cross mcmayhem
team recently so a lot of household
names that you probably know rich
Froning yeah they've done inside tracker
and have found you know a lot of value
in it so what do you find when you look
at these athletes is the obviously we
don't need to go into specific details
and find out that Katherine's actually
got slightly high glucose we see a lot
of trends with especially high level
CrossFit athletes where they're CK is
usually a little bit higher which just
means it's just a creatine kinase which
is a marker of overtraining so you would
expect to see you know that marker be a
little bit high based on how often
they're training how many hours they're
putting in per day we also have seen
glucose in CrossFitters be a little bit
up on the higher end which is something
that you noticed in your yes and it's
just because for whatever reason they're
not eating enough soluble fiber which is
exactly what I think you were told this
morning on your console yeah so I had
yourself and one of your colleagues run
me through my results earlier on today I
I only saw that I wouldn't be I would be
further out than I was I was expecting
after a decade and a half of club
promotion and under sleeping and some
periods of pretty significant
overtraining as well I was expecting my
inner age to come back at like 45 and
further just to be like every sound and
alarm going off inside of inside tracker
like that the air-raid siren goes off
and then the remedy pick up this guy
make sure he's not dead yeah
I mean so but it turns out that it
wasn't a burden that glucose just a
little bit how free testosterone was low
yeah I'm gonna guess is typical yeah of
people who train a lot mm-hmm
and yet have some more soluble fiber and
and stop taking a multivitamin and then
see where you're at in three months what
what do you see with endurance athletes
though so for endurance athletes it's
different it's more micronutrient
related we see 50 percent of our female
population having low ferritin so the
storage form of iron yeah so that's 50
percent of women under the age of 50
that are doing insight tracker so this
is someone that is proactive about their
health and thinking about these types of
things so I would extrapolate to say
that the general population of runners
is probably little bit higher than that
so we can say you know there's a pretty
high chance that by doing this and
knowing your numbers you'll improve your
energy yes low testosterone is also a
common trend what else we see the liver
enzymes elevated we see the creatine
kinase elevated so all of these
indicators of overtraining or not
resting enough because like CrossFit
running is addictive and you want to do
more of it and these athletes are
allergic to rest and and so you know
it's like oh when was your last like
even just trying to schedule the test
it's best done after a rest day or an
easy day well I don't have those yeah
it's like okay you don't have to do
inside checker to know that like you
should probably have a few of those in
your in your program so for a lot of
people fundamentally it's a shift of
okay here's some data that says you're
worked maybe maybe we back off a little
bit on the on the volume perspective and
then the other big one is caloric needs
so many runners are running a lot or
even if they're not running a lot then
they're running more than they're eating
so they're not eating enough to to
replenish the energy that they're that
they're burning and so that puts you at
risk for injury and it puts you
for overtraining and burnout and all
that stuff that you know we want to
avoid so when I did my own consult with
our dietician she basically said you're
you're under my 500 calories every day
and that's not on long round days so
it's like okay let's find another meal
or another like two or three snacks
how does undereating manifest in the
bloodwork so for me it was a combination
of high cortisol LDL was unopposed and
the free testosterone had been had gone
down a little bit given an increase in
training so I you know test quarterly
and I was able to see as my training
ramped up those things all went the
wrong way
and so we went through and also the
soluble fiber and so this was January of
2018 and I'm doing like 20% more mileage
than I've ever done
eating more and getting more results and
it hadn't been injured knock on wood but
it was a no brainer like hey this is
something that's a problem it's very
clearly identified in the blood work and
now it's having you know action-reaction
it's taking a look s what go isn't it
yeah for sure yeah I mean you remove the
the you know where do I focus what
supplements do I need I know what I need
Kerry knows what she needs and you know
what you need and there's probably some
overlap in that but if I were to take
what Kerry needed or I were to take what
you needed that wouldn't that's not what
we need so it's it's understanding your
personalized supplement routine and pay
something something as simple as that
it's also like what you need to eat and
for I was not told that I was under a
day just FYI
after I got my consult but if you're
doing something where you're using
templates or your macro counting and you
want to try to meet those numbers but
you want to try to meet them with the
right foods now you have something
telling you exactly what your body needs
so that was really helpful for me to
know like for you what you were told
that you needed to eat a lot of beans it
was helpful for me to know 20 different
times
yeah lots of validates my my sushi habit
okay yeah because you vision and
shellfish okay so that was keeping you
optimal yeah fantastic I mean anything
that excuses you to eat more sushi or
more of what you want yeah sweet one
thing that I thought was super
interesting when I was looking at the
recommendations I don't I don't know
what I was expecting the recommendations
to be I think I maybe thought there
would be something crazy complex out the
other side of it but having spoken to
one of your colleagues why I discovered
was that between sleep training diet and
supplementation those are the only
inputs that we need to be looking at to
manipulate everything that's going on
with regards to our blood work right I
don't know what I thought I was gonna
expect to see Thanks it was some I don't
know I don't know what expecting like
just something crazy complex that was
totally out of the realm of oh well your
ions out so you need to do this
ridiculous thing yes but it's not it's
everything's within your control yeah so
adoption is like the whole program is
worthless if you can't take the data and
make meaning of it so there there's a
lot of you look at pro sports there's a
lot of meaningless tracking that's going
on and like people are people are
tracking GPS people are tracking sleep
people are tracking power people are
tracking all these things that that pro
athletes are having tracks but it's just
sitting in a in a portfolio similar yeah
exactly and and I was at the national
strength and conditioning Association
conference a couple years ago and and
one of the presenters was basically
saying stop tracking just to tell your
boss you're tracking this it's a waste
of your athletes time and it's a waste
of your time if you're not doing
anything with it and and so our our goal
is to to make everything that we asked
of you and everything that we take from
you literally your blood meaningful and
so you may have noticed that there were
a lot of questions on the registration
process yes
we don't ask anything that we don't use
anywhere none of it's just for fun
none of its for statistical purposes on
our end everything that we asked on that
registration process is used in a
recommendation somewhere mm-hmm one of
the things that the dietician I was
speaking to earlier on mentioned was
that if she had the choice she would
have actually had like a 120 question
questionnaire partly the 16 major food
groups density in questions that relate
to each of those right but she was like
I would be looking at breaking breaking
down your veggies in like dark leafy
greens and little veggies and timing and
frequency and its quality and all sorts
of stuff but I guess you guys have to
mediate between how much are we going to
get people to actually fill this in
questions yeah yeah you're gonna get
zero compliance or lower compliance but
you need to mediate that with getting
sufficient data right so that you guys
can actually make it useful I suppose
and it needs to be realistic for people
to get recommendations for them and be
able to implement them in everyday life
like Jonathan said so it can't be you
know a huge stretch like one of our
recommendations is to adopt a vegetarian
diet for a day and that's only if they
per week a day per week and that's only
if you eat a small amount of meat so if
it's someone who is telling us they're
eating you know meat every single day
we're not gonna go tell you to be a
vegetarian because that's unrealistic
for that person so it's making a simple
simple change versus a complete overhaul
yeah I wouldn't I wonder how many people
at home they're listening on one of the
extreme ends of the spectrum one where
they are doing data masturbation right
and and over tracky and everything is
done I've got a couple of buddies who do
that with their work Pomodoro's so they
know every 25 minutes of their day they
know exactly what they've done yeah and
then I'm sure that there will be a lot
of people on the other end of the
spectrum who are just flying blind yeah
but yeah you are right this
kind of addiction that some of us get
into which I've swung in and out of you
guys paralysis by analysis absolutely
yeah you are right so for the normal
everyday person we've spoken about
athletes for someone who's just looking
to exist through life feeling better
mhm is blood work going to identify why
they may have particular allergies to
foods or particular deficiencies that
could lead to more more serious problems
down the line is it an early warning
system for some people or are there any
other things to do with longevity that
you guys really focus on so the company
was started for that first point it
wasn't to help elite athletes you know
squeeze out an extra 1% our founder Gill
blander had a death in the family when
he was a little kid and he said I want
to live forever and so this is his
project of you know how does how does he
live longer live better and he went the
route of academia and he said you know I
can publish the papers that some
scientists will see or it can start a
company and impact you know tens of
millions or hundreds of millions of
people billions of people and so he went
with option number two and or he went
without to number one at first and then
you know transition over option number
two and and so the initial mission of
the company was like I said was not to
help elite athletes but rather help
anyone have more energy or better sleep
or whatever athletes need that
performance whereas most people want to
feel better but the program works the
same way for for those two people it
work it works it uses scientific studies
to provide recommendations to help
achieve goals specific goals that that
are relevant to you even if the goal is
just to feel more calm well yep lose
some weight exactly and then the food
sensitivity question is when we get
asked a lot at this time we aren't
confident enough in the science and
validity behind food sensitivity testing
so we don't include it it's incredibly
expensive and doesn't provide much
utility on our end so instead of you
know
just trying to make a few more bucks
providing a service that isn't as good
of a quality we just don't do it
I think definitely based on what I've
seen of what you guys have given me as a
feedback remembering that you don't know
why I eat typically the things that were
highlighted by deficiencies in my
profile seem to tie in very close
relative what I know that I don't eat
red so like beans and oatmeal problem to
know me I just need a minute
I do just need to eat more beans
apparently we had an athlete they wrote
a blog about you know beans are our it
was a hilarious title and I'm blanking
on what it was but basically beans are
her end-all be-all solution so what do
you think moving forward are going to be
the how would we say what's the future
of this industry look like with regards
to blood work and stuff like that is it
the sort of thing that's going to become
adopted by more people or is it still
going to remain for elite athletes
what's the trend suggesting at the
moment do you think um I mean I think
there's so many ways that obviously
contract different things about yourself
now there's we can use the DNA plus
blood that we offer which if you have
your DNA sequenced and you also have
your blood work done through us we can
otherwise just blast myself in the face
with a glass of water we can use both of
those pieces of information to give you
an even more detailed look at not only
what's going on inside your body right
now but what you are what you are
predisposed to because of what your DNA
is into a genetic condition right and
stuff like that David was discussing his
passion Aussie Jew genes that he's got
when he was just lambaste in them saying
how it means that he's got a
predisposition to be fat and he's candy
daring it's he's guys shape with dairy
he's not very good with I think like
wheat or something else as well and yeah
I mean all of the things we are this
some of our nature and our nature right
and if the nature and the environment is
able to be
represented in the blood work that you
guys do now and that the nature is able
to be represented in your genes you do
have a pretty comprehensive picture of
exactly what's going on inside of you I
wonder
moving forward whether or not things
like this and more consistent testing
cuz you guys suggest a test every three
months right so all right so like the
gold standard yeah mm-hmm and that's to
see do something get recommendations
make changes reassess right so we
understand that that's not that's not
gonna work for everyone with their
budget or with you know getting into a
lab whatnot so we're looking to add in
more inputs that are sort of lower
friction points so adding in Fitbit
adding in garment adding in this
physiological data so that you can say
okay my goal is to boost sleep quality
I've improved my magnesium or I improved
my vitamin D and I see that I see a
related improvement in sleep quality or
my sleep quality is poor let's look at
diet about you know around how can we
how can we manipulate diet knowing what
we already know about you to make a
recommendation around improving sleep
quality so the the goal is and then you
know adding things like microbiome were
things things as the science continues
to support it what are all the inputs
that we can just mash into the you know
inside tracker approach of taking
science distilling it into
recommendations and and helping you
improve that's that's the art process
and the more we can load into the into
the top here though the better and more
personalized the recommendations and
improvements can be so you guys are
working I'm gonna guess
majority of you on the front end dealing
with athletes yep speaking to people so
on and so forth what are the people that
are dealing with the back end the
science and the data like are they just
like they looked into the matrix like
Karen I joked that were the only two
people in the entire company without
advanced credentials and it's literally
a couple of that is off to its
everyone else's got like a couple
letters in front of their very smart
very personal it's a good mix of like
super cool nerds yeah
today is everyone in one form or another
ring of fitness all sorts for the most
part yeah yeah so like our our company
outings we went boxing and bowling you
want boxing boxing was it nice to be so
intense
honestly for a company outing it was 10
million times
checking over to make sure our CEO
wasn't like flatlined on the ground that
is funny
yeah so do you guys understand or can
you explain a little bit about the
process of what happens when science
comes in because it sounds like from the
consultation had earlier and from
speaking to you guys here until you're
absolutely dead on that the science is
going to back up something you're not
actually going to be using him so what's
the process of I guess absorbing the
science and then delivering it to the
system is it to the super super nodes
yeah we so we have a team of thousands
of interns that are typing away on the
computer it's a dozen or so yeah
constantly researching new studies and
constantly looking looking at things
that are be the biggest priority like
for for the endurance athletes it's an
iron group how do we make the iron
recommendations better or how do we we
just added hemoglobin a1c how do we lump
glucose with hemoglobin a1c and make
recommendations so they're either
looking for new studies or they're
looking for specific topics and they
find something they talked about it in
their and their science meeting it's
and the way it works is it's it's it's
an algorithm so it's a big if-then
statement so if this then that
so they're whole bunch of rules in the
system and the rules are written by the
scientists but it can't just be
scientist one saying hey here's
something cool loaded in yeah its
scientist one for proposes a rule has to
be validated by a second person and then
it can be added into the plans like an
internal peer review system almost yep
of peer reviewed studies yes so there
there's two behaviors by the FDA each
one exactly so we're getting the best of
the best from the best
and then there's an algorithm that goes
into ranking the recommendations so we
have recommendations from one to five
stars that are that that system is is
based on the recency of the study the
type of the study the number of people
and declare certain seats or the
reputation right it's like the beam
thing is is a five step the oatmeal is a
five star recommendation but but there
are being things I'm gonna keep drilling
this beam you need ninety nine cents so
the beam thing is is something we're
very confident in yes and I've stopped
yeah
whereas there are other things that you
know supplement recommendations yeah
that might not be as as stronger or not
it's still valid and it's that but there
haven't been you know ten Studies on on
garlic for glucose levels or something
like that let's say that someone who's
at home might be feeling like they're
just a little bit out do you see we
discussed typical trends amongst
high-performing athletes is there
anything that you think or that you see
consistently that you think people
should consider doing immediately even
before they can sit again in the
bloodwork done and there's some things
someone's like oh man
energy levels are a little bit low what
my mood appears to be a little bit out
on my trainings a little bit out there's
some some kind of very common issues
that you tend to come up against that
you could recommend for people to maybe
try do this first and
I do not first I mean I would say the
easiest one and probably the most
important that I can think of is just
sleep a lot of people who come to us
their cortisol is way off and it's
because they're not getting enough sleep
so our biggest recommendations or just
cut the screen time shut your phone off
the half-hour before you actually go to
sleep so that when you are sleeping it's
eight quality hours and not you know off
and on yeah not good rum so I would say
that that's a big one that we do see a
lot of and and just something easy that
you can implement here daily like
everyone's already doing it right what
else is there anything else that you see
that tends to be reflected in terms of
diet is there no eating or eating too
much of something I know you know the
stuff yes so we see 82% of Americans
with elevated glucose and the bassy to
pay 2% so for the majority of people
adding oatmeal into their diet is the
best possible thing that they can do
really we elevated glucose oatmeal
oatmeal we looked at as we post a paper
on the impact of algorithm-based
recommendations or the personalized
nutrition model that we follow and we
were able to look at recommendations
interventions and improvement and so we
could see that that some things worked
better than others in terms of
compliance like another one we found was
that the only thing that will improve
low vitamin low enough vitamin D levels
is taking a vitamin D supplement which
sounds like it makes sense but yeah oh
stand outside for 20 minutes a day
didn't do it didn't work yeah eat more
fatty fish didn't work
eat more mushrooms didn't work so so
yeah back to the glucose thing so if you
do nothing else eat more oatmeal we
looked at what are some of the best
interventions across the board for men
based on biomarkers eating nuts on a
daily basis is any specific type of nuts
whatever whatever you'll you know
whatever you want really yeah almonds
walnuts etc
that improves glucose lipids
testosterone liver enzyme inflammation
and most of those metrics make up our
inner age score as well with glucose
having the highest weight so if you're
looking at one specific food they can
address the the bulk of the metrics that
impact male longevity the most yeah
nuts yes that's uh well that's right I
can't isness I can't I can't get around
and uh again I don't know what I was
expecting to see or hear about training
recovery or training sleep supplements
and diet I don't know what I was
expecting but they've trained harder
yeah yeah I don't know I don't know what
I thought it was gonna be like you had
to go and do some like to open my
meditation yeah I was gonna have to do
whatever lives in there yeah you
probably see that for for colors are
interesting so you guys have got so much
taker on the back end and you say you
starting to publish papers now is there
a plan longer-term with what you're
going to do with the data obviously
people have got like privacy and stuff
yeah that but in terms of trends and
things the amount data that you guys are
capturing must be pretty powerful yeah
we feel it's the largest database of
healthy people that exists in the world
and largest database of healthy people
that exists in the world
yep yeah so like Point Blank that's
pretty powerful and then you guys you're
know the tip of the spear with regards
to making sure that any analysis of this
is as optimal as it could be right for
sure and it's a huge opportunity and
it's why the company was created that's
Gil's dream to have this power to impact
millions and billions of people he
looked at me one day we were in a
meeting talking about you know do we go
after thousands do we focus on millions
and Gil was like seven billion that's
our number is just get everyone and yeah
and and he was totally serious
like his mission is to help every human
on the planet and however we
there that's how we're gonna get there
but yeah I mean you look at in the paper
we published we have some charts that
are able to look at correlations between
as this goes this way this goes this way
this data doesn't exist anywhere else
because there aren't people doing full
you know 43 plus biomarker tests on
healthy people some of these tests are
usually run on sick people to address
from a medical standpoint but we're able
to see statistically significant changes
and make better recommendations from it
is the is that a floor in human nature
is a floor in medicine at the moment
that people only seem to look at getting
this sort of thing done when there's a
problem yeah definitely a flaw in
medicine yeah yeah I mean we we got a
every you know once or twice or
sometimes three times a year we'll get a
customer the customer will tell us that
they were charged by quest for the blood
draw so you walk into quest and hand
them your insurance card and say here's
what I'm testing you're paying two
thousand dollars for our 589 plan and so
it's it's unattainable for most people
outside of inside the way that the the
medical world currently operates yes you
either can't get this done or it's
outrageously expensive one of the
reasons you can't get it done is because
it's not the area of expertise for a
physician and so they're not going to do
it they're not gonna do something it's a
you know we're talking about before
monitoring data and not doing with it
something with it they're not they're
incentivized to not do that and they're
incentivized to do things that they can
help you with and they that's not their
area of expertise that are essential in
what they do but they're you know go to
a dietician or or use insight tracker or
something like that that can help you
with with the blood work yeah and it's
really preventive health care instead of
just reactionary health care and that's
the goal is to have everyone do it and
everyone's had their you know
what work done at some point in their
life yeah so but not everyone's got
these recommendations right right so for
the majority of people the the data you
get for from your physical is enough to
use for a $49 DIY plan and get guidance
on glucose and lipids and so it'll tell
you it'll probably tell you don't meal
and beans and nuts but for the most part
you can't just hear that and and know
you want something in front right so
this is like a personal invitation I
have a friend who she's an elite
marathoner and the way she described it
was like I know that I need to sleep
more and I know that I need to eat more
and I know that I need to take an iron
supplement but it took seeing it in
front of me to see this is Julia's needs
to-do list
yeah versus like yeah most people should
probably do these things perfect example
of that is I've got a back injury for a
year now and only recently did I get an
MRI I've been doing my rehab and I've
been kind of moving in and out of
different types of rehab movements but
it was only until I saw that I've got
two bulging discs l5 s1 right and I've
got smalls node as its called
for me to actually go right stop
thinking that you can do a lighter
version of what you've been doing
quadrupled down on your rehab and let's
get this fixed right there's something
about seeing it in front of your face
and so we've talked about nuts
oatmeal sleep is there anything else is
there anything else that people tends to
be lacking in which manifests itself in
the day of the you guys see I would say
iron in women Jonathan already touched
on that the Feridun Zion in women iron I
mean women though
we see it moved early in women
especially Feridun which is your is a
marker of your iron storage in your body
so we see that fatigue you know he sees
that tends to be low um and just like
Jonathan said if that happens then you
know even getting on a bed can be a
large task because you just have no
energy so obviously training is out of
the question so if you had a goal in
mind of running a race or doing
spec competition you know something like
a low ferritin level can really step in
your way
what's the things for them depends hello
yeah you can fix it through food or your
supplementation so if you super low you
need to bring in the big guns yeah a
supplement yep
you guys give out an inner age figure
what's that mean ladies inner age so
inner age is the age that your body is
on the inside versus what the number
says on your driver's license so it's
your I like that that's good and we use
five markers that we've determined are
the most important from the markers that
we test in terms of longevity so glucose
alt HSC RP vitamin D and testosterone
okay and all those are in bind those
combined will give you your inner age
I'm 31 in mine stage that I'm 36 that is
because I have quite high glucose I'm
right in thinking that that is one of
the most heavily weighted it is yeah why
is that the case
research on longevity correlating glue
code consistently optimized glucose to
better longevity okay and 86% of
Americans have high glucose 82% 82% yep
what's that Shih Tzu like why is that
why is that the case is it high carb
diet I mean how long have you how long
have you been in the States
yeah yeah a couple of weeks there's a
lot of a lot of big servings a lot of
sugary food yep sedentary lifestyle I
don't know it does it just surprised me
because although since I've been here
there are some large servings and some
large people as well um although that's
the case there's more wellness out here
then there is in the UK as well but
you've been in LA and Boston yes so so
is that one representative LA and Boston
or LA in particular is a very wellness
this place I was just in Nashville
Tennessee for the weekend very not a
wellness conscious place so you get
places like that that you know it's a
sign of status to to go out to eat all
the time and and we have research that
shows the more you go out to eat the
more likely you are to have elevated
glucose and ready true yeah and is that
one of the things that you guys ask
can't remember whether it was okay how
often do you eat out or get takeout okay
and and so I mean that that that's true
in other places in the country too like
if you eat out a lot maybe that's a good
thing maybe less control of your diet
usually when you eat out right for sure
yeah and and even if you order if you're
if you're intense are good like I'm
gonna get a salmon with you know
whatever you're getting sugar the mashed
potatoes and you're getting sugar in the
sauce and you're getting sauce and all
these different things that you have no
control over so some of our
recommendations are around you know
we've done blogs where we talk about
like you're at a restaurant and and you
can ask for your food however the hell
you want it it doesn't have to be what's
on the menu but yeah so so getting back
to your question of why why do we think
it's so elevated sedentary lifestyle
people are sitting from 9 to 5 every day
and they're exhausted by the time they
go home so they're not going to the gym
and they sleep or they don't sleep and
they do they do it all over again the
next day and and it's like a status
symbol to be busy and and being busy is
glamorized and so if you're busy all the
time you can't do the things that you
need to do for yourself and so you're
putting other things in the priority and
your health is the cost the comment
about being busy being seen as a sign of
state this was something that I was
reading by the guys that make the
six-minute diary that did a free pdf
called the golden evening routine yep
and they talk exactly about that the
once society praises busyness it's a
rite of passage in a badge of honor
right that people who again after it
yeah Gary Vaynerchuk and all of the
listeners at home will know my opinions
about Gary Vaynerchuk I mean he's going
to die a lot earlier than the rest of us
because you can't talk about hustling
grind and sleep three hours a night Gary
like because it's biology right now you
do because your body will break down
there there are anomalies to that we
same it's ascent the genetic code if
that's the same likelihood is he being
hit by lightning right apparently to get
that that genetic mutation right and and
those people are all at the top because
they have stuff going for them in their
genetics and and because we have an
athlete that that just raced or just
broken fastest no time running south to
north of Israel 1,000 kilometers become
ten plus days and he slept three hours
at night just go through yeah running
sixty six miles a day or 100 a little
over a hundred K a day and and he he
does blood work through and such record
and he just ran ten marathons in ten
days like two three weeks ago and and
his data is great and he doesn't sleep a
lot and and I'm sure he would be better
if he slept more yeah but he is the
exception to the rule that like you must
get six hours of sleep or you must get
seven hours of sleep he literally does
everything and and he's able to do his
job he's able to be with his family he's
able to do sponsor obligations things
like that but but he's the like 0.00001%
and there's almost nobody like him but
the people that are like him are all at
the top and and they're all role models
of people or like I'm gonna be just like
this person and and you can aspire to do
some things so they're similar but like
if it's not in your if it's not in your
nature to like not need that
which it is for the majority of us
you're gonna burn out and you're gonna
get injured and you're not gonna enjoy
what you're doing you're gonna fall
behind did a podcast recently with James
clear you know the raw atomic habits and
he was talking about how our genetics
they do not predetermine but they do
predispose right and I think that that
as a little guiding influence yeah
towards what people do in their lives
right like if you struggle to put on
muscle trying to become a power lifter
is probably about everything you might
enjoy it but you're not gonna you know
gonna plan the best and if the exactly
and I suppose that you know your guy
like if if he was I don't know say a
long-distance truck driver it's probably
wasted in that industry like where you
don't take a timer and you got to be off
the clock ten hours or eight hours or
whatever it might be like this guy
doesn't need it I mean it's the guy that
can go rather he's found himself an
industry road in which he can find that
so moving forward what do you see the
future of this industry looking like of
you guys got any new markers in the
pipeline that you want to use and then
on top of that what do you think in
terms of technology and stuff like that
is there anything that the super nerds
have told you about that's kind of
coming up well we're looking not marker
wise but we're looking to add more
mindfulness recommendations to the
platform as well so for something like
cortisol to implement yoga if you told
us that you weren't doing that kind of
exercise now so things like that we're
looking to add how would that manifest
and would that be cortisol again really
in the blood work yeah so so it's not
only looking at specific lifestyle
interventions that we hadn't either
considered we hadn't done a lot of
research on but also more inputs as we
were talking about before
and so physiological monitoring
microbiome things like that that are
more new compared to blood analysis
and then getting like talk about super
nerd we can go super nerd on this let's
go super imagine you get a notification
from your phone that knows your blood
work it knows your calendar it knows the
weather and it note let's say your your
vitamin D is low or your your cortisol
is high and you have back to back to
back to back meetings but hey you've got
this block of 15 minutes at 2:00 o'clock
and it's sunny oh go take a walk you get
a ping hey it's it's it's sunny out and
you have this this little you know
stretch of time that's it's available
take advantage of it
so it's knowing they'll be so sick
wouldn't it yeah super nerdy stuff but
but people people would dig that some
people would dig that so it's it's stuff
like that our CEO jokes I don't know if
it's a joke though about spitting on
your iPhone and getting data and getting
immediate recommendations that's
probably a long way away but it's not
outside their own possibility name has
been talk I've been hearing on some
podcast recently about future technology
to do it like nanotech why you can have
these receptors that would just be
placed in your blood
yeah and they'll just be flowing around
you all the time giving like I think
it's a James Bond in fact I'm sorry so
that's why they like shoot something in
a zone and then if they're like his
heart rates elevated and it's fixed he's
having sex a lot yeah I mean like
there's something for everyone but no
meaning like you can go you can go as
advanced as as that or you can you can
you know peel back a few few less layers
you know and and look at it through your
iPhone or you know some who that mm-hm
yeah I do get that I think talking about
the sort of the cultures and stuff like
that something that I've definitely
noticed there's a difference between the
UK and the US is that busyness culture
yeah like the u.s. actually seems to be
a little bit more relaxed I think that
the UK and
be interested to hear if the listeners
agree I think that the UK does I don't
know what they're busy doing because
they're not getting they're not getting
after it there's not this kind of
entrepreneurship yeah thing below the
lines that there appears to be in the
u.s. so you spent time in two very busy
places yes so you're getting like the
representative something yeah but it's
it's true everywhere and and there are
so many books and podcasts about like
more more more more more you must do
more and and that leads to burnout
now we're getting books and podcasts
going the other way that says you know
you need to you know you have your rest
day for for training you need a rest day
for for life or like yeah exactly and
and so we're getting to a point where
like I have I have an Instagram account
with a couple friends called red state
brags and and it one of them is an
Olympian and the other is a professional
trail runner and obstacle course racer
so like they have some pedigree behind a
success and they both run themselves
into the ground by trying to do
everything the one that went to the
Olympics so ten years ago now is still
just now getting out of that hole does
she put herself in really and so we're
we're glamourizing like sat on my couch
for the afternoon
you like the only intervals I did today
were couch to fridge and like stuff like
that that that we're getting messages
from people that are like oh my god I
thought it was the only person that the
you know struggles with with taking time
off or sleeping in or like we now have
people bragging like got eight hours of
sleep that's such a good rhetoric to be
pushing I've never I've never heard of
anyone who does that but you are talking
right it's just not it's not glamorized
it associated with being lazy laziness
and complacency and not making the most
of minute right but if it's part of the
plan I'm sure that Ben Bergeron even
with his making the most minutes
strategy I'm sure that some of those
minutes are rest I mean every Friday
yeah is is
Rizzoli's right through comp train I
don't know if everyone has the same rest
but there's definitely both in rest days
and that perfect example despite the
fact that United Airlines broke my phone
holder which is why I've got some
slightly odd camera angles today I
noticed that as you go through their
in-flight entertainment they have a head
space up huh and they're now that helps
you fall asleep on plane yeah I mean
Andy pettite um he's gained absolutely
every ways partnered with night it's
partnered with the United Airlines but
you know the fact that meditation has
been adopted by airplane yeah literally
available on the street you know you
think like what my gonna do I'll watch
another Harry Potter movie we're
Avengers or something like known in an
meditate based on this and it's curated
though being on a plane and that was
like known because I'm not I wasn't on
the Instagram at the time taking a
selfie of it so I think that as we
continue to move forward and as
technology like with bands and like
inside tracker and stuff continue to
move forward that hopefully more people
will be able to understand what's going
on inside of their bodies but one of the
things that I do worry about is that
paralysis by analysis thing that you
were talking about the people become so
bogged down in the day to it that they
don't really get anywhere is the is the
onus on the people to fix that or is it
on the platform to make sure that it's
giving them the right the right output
because obviously if people are just
drowning in data like what do they do
with it I think that thing that we try
to do is out of all of these things that
we can recommend for you we try to have
you choose you know between three and
seven of these recommendations that we
give you that you can actually use you
know every day or every week so if you
narrow those recommendations down to
only three or only five then you're not
going to be bogged down with having to
change so many things about
your life you can continue to live
continue to train to recover and if you
make these important changes then it
will move the needle for you so for us I
think that's you know an important part
of of what we do incremental changes
right what do you guys see so to begin
to round up what do you see as a an
impact on your athletes performance have
you got any stats like that obviously
I'm gonna guess they won't be put in the
5k times in vs. all of their other
things but do you see any um so it's
it's hard to get that on the individual
athletes we've looked at some of the
data around pro teams we've worked with
related to injuries so games lost look
at the San Jose Sharks they've they've
had a lot of success with that try
improving travel improving around travel
so again the San Jose Sharks had the
year that we did this analysis they had
the best away record in the league
meaning they were able to manage travel
the best based on the data that they
were collecting around when do we change
practices and and how do we improve you
know how do I make this skate optional
and this skate required and get the
players to buy-in that they should sleep
in on this day and they should they
should show up on this day so so we
looked at some data around that I'm not
sure we have much else at the
organizational level at the team level
but injuries gonna be such a big deal
yeah so injuries of just a manifestation
that something is being pushed so far
and that something might have just been
formed right it's not always gonna
manifest that someone's poor deadlift
posture right isn't necessarily gonna
show up in the blood walk exactly we
don't know there being an NBA team that
the design ition squad shaming so we had
an
a dietitian that that came to us and
said I think I think paleo is a problem
and I think it's a problem for our
athletes because they're tired and
injured all the time and and something's
a problem and she was like she was like
and I'm the dietician and they're not
listening to to my nutrition advice so I
need this bulwark dog who's doing the
paleo that the athletes athletes that
they know better than I - yes
so the the culture at in some of these
organizations is they listen to the
strength coach or they listen to the
head trainer they listen to some some
guy that's been in the organization or
in the sport for 20-30 years whereas the
dietitians are credentialed they went to
school for nutrition and they that's
their job so she was able to get the
blood work done and came back and she's
like I'm right check that out yeah now
let's make some changes and injuries
went down and fatigue went you know
improved it's not to say inside tracker
improve their injuries and fatigue but
the platform that we allowed them to you
that we that we were able to have them
use allowed them to show their athletes
look this is a problem your lipids are
out of whack your courtesans
through-the-roof calories blah blah blah
vitamin D here's hard data is showing
you what to do and and it's saying
exactly what I'm saying now I'm gonna
help you implement it and she did and it
worked
you're totally right about that it comes
back to the example that I said earlier
on about the MRI yeah like you got a
single sore it in front of my eyes and
because everyone wants to take the path
of least resistance
no no not me that's not yummy no no
that's everyone else
I'm the 18% yes absolutely I know when
you think when you think like that you
actually end up doing yourself a
disservice because you believe that
you're not culpable to the trends of the
market you're like no no no no you are
they did it by its very [ __ ] nature
it's more likely that you are then
you're right it's like when people
complain about try
right like you are traffic I think it's
hilarious it's like so anyway it's the
same thing it's like well that's not my
problem I'm just out for a Monday
morning drive at 8:30 in the morning
yeah I do totally get it um I think if
it's good enough for David Sinclair it's
good enough for me and that was that was
like the first thing that I saw when I
was talking to him today how much he is
uh how much he is reliant on having
something that comes out of the back end
right because making the changes it
would be the same as it'd be the same as
doing everything that CrossFit it does
our strength as liters or a run at us
without actually doing strength CrossFit
or running right yeah you'd be like Ron
goodness make sure I get enough sleep
make sure again if this I'm gonna make
sure again if that but I'm not actually
going to do the thing that tests all of
the inroads it's the output right and
the output for most people is training
but also should be right some form of
blood work I think you know it doesn't
surprise me that this is coming out of
America and not from the UK I know that
you guys offer a service in the UK and
that people in the UK are listening can
get their work done link will be in the
show notes below as always but the USA
generally to me leads it kind of leads
the UK with this we're lagging behind
like people are silly like mince pies
seamless food beingness foods there even
be in the sphere to say but it honestly
like like you know the wedges of oranges
as a like halftime to rugby yeah just
ease it's still a thing like it so
there's so my best memories of third
grid wedges of orange soccer you know
yep fair enough I mean we've we've
adopted you at least yeah I genuinely do
hope that this is going to make people
think with more care about what they're
doing because in the same way as the
mechanism
makes mobility work for a lot of people
effective from rolling and passive
stretching and massage therapy
professor Cohen hanok doctor of physical
therapy for yoga no training systems on
episode 13 I want to say said that the
mechanism that those things are working
on isn't what people think but if it
makes them think about their recovery
then it is enough and that's kind of
almost what we're talking about here
that maybe even the blood worth
something to me potentially with all of
the markers I might not have known that
these things were going to be out of
whack but it was probably pretty likely
that I was going to have low free
testosterone because I'm overtraining
probably like fairly common that the
oatmeal and the beans etc etc but
because I wasn't thinking about it it
wasn't something that needed to you
don't know what you don't know there we
go so guys I'm really excited to go and
have a look at the unit which is next
door so throughout this episode everyone
will have been seeing all of the footage
from behind the scenes can you very
briefly take us through what your
facility is and what will be what we'll
be looking at sure so it is a it's a
shared workspace we are in Cambridge
Massachusetts which is right outside of
Boston or up nerd central central yeah
this is where in Harvard no seriously
this is you're looking at MIT right over
there
Harvard is where you came from just up
the river toughest is one of the top
nutrition programs in the country and
yeah it's the epicenter of education and
health and technology Google and
Facebook Amazon external all within ya
50 feet of here Wow
so so you're in the right place yeah
well guys thank you very much for your
time
I really appreciate you coming up thank
you for having me out here um I'm
looking forward to seeing what happens
if I do change up these my beans if I
change up my oatmeal and I hope that the
listeners at home as well will have
started to realize how important is
consider these sort of things in the
same way as David Sinclair I was talking
about the fact that people believe that
aging is just this process that were
along for the ride with I think people
believe that a degree of ignorance of
what is happening inside of their body
is also like oh well I'm just I don't
know how dice I can't see what's in my
blood I can't see what the food how food
affect me and things like that and I
think that um hopefully as companies
like yourselves and individuals like
David begin to make people think with
more granularity and like a higher
resolution about exactly what they're
doing with the health it's not just
enough to be like oh well like I'm
making sure that I'm taking the stairs
to work right so okay like yep fair
enough like that might've been a thing
thirty years ago a tray went up fifty
years ago when doctors were still
smoking like they still are whether
you're not smoking in the delivery table
true I saw an advert not long ago that
said it was for Camel cigarettes and the
statistic was more doctors smoke camels
than any other cigarette and he was a
doctor at like at surgery like smoking
yeah terrifying but yeah guys if you are
interested in getting your blood work -
and a link will be in the show notes
below - the inside track of website I
will also probably be discussing exactly
what we went through on one of the
catch-up episodes coming up soon as well
but for now thank you very much for your
time it's been awesome thanks Chris
thank you
[Music]
you